quand vous faites plus de 5%, vous êtes
remboursé de
47,5% de ce que vous avez dépensé dire
si vous avez des pensées le plafond
c'est 16 millions d'euros on peut pas
dépenser plus au premier tour et bah
vous touchez donc environ 8 millions
d'euros dans les différentiel entre 8
millions d'euros et 800000 €, c'est déjà
énorme mais par rapport à 8 millions
c'est rien c'est incroyable et comme
Pécresse donc là Monsieur elle pense
16 millions d'euros on a dépensé 15 le
problème c'est qu'elle était sûr dans sa
tête de faire plus de 5 bah oui on sait
toucher les 8 et elle s'est engagée
personnellement elle s'est engagée
personnellement elle apprenne après
un patrimoine important l'avait dit vous
savez son patrimoine virgule 7 millions
donc 4 millions en immobilier là elle
s'est elles ont une réunion de famille
hier en voyant ce qui pouvait vendre
soit une maison soit un appartement soit
des actions mais elle doit rembourser au
15 mai si vous c'était comme ça hier
Patrick elle a
et si vous vendez en un mois d'ici le 15
mai forcément vous bravez vous vendez
moins cher vous faites une moins-value
la campagne a coûté 15 millions le parti
lui a déjà donné 5 millions puis après
2,5 millions puis après ils ont
abandonné 2,5 millions donc avec
l'argent des militants en fait et donc
il lui reste effectivement 5 millions à
sa charge ah ouais c'est quand même on
ne va pas pleurer pour Valérie
sinon enfin excusez-moi pardon mais
c'est on est vraiment mais on marche sur
la tête parce que là vous avez mis
beaucoup de mots énervé
quelle idée dans un appel c'est le
contraire de mélaïm en fait non mais
c'est le négatif de Beney mais Naïm elle
est toujours gentil toi et elle elle dit
que des mots vénère alors je vais vous
expliquer très calmement à peine
l'élection terminée elle passe à un
appel au don't j'ai trouvé que c'était
mauvais genre est-ce que c'est possible
de faire ça non en fait un moment elle
cite Nicolas pernicoff
regardez
la situation
financière de ma campagne et désormais
critique les républicains ne peuvent pas
faire face à ses dépenses
je suis endettée personnellement à
hauteur de 5 millions d'euros
c'est pour cela que je lance ce matin un
appel national au don j'ai besoin de
votre aide d'urgence il en va de la
survie des républicains et au-delà de la
survie de la droite républicaine
mobiliser
vous pour Valérie Pécresse non mais
sérieux c'est un truc de fou là
avec moi plus faire un brushing
pour se dire on va peut-être être
présidente c'est l'ego et derrière c'est
un truc de fou moi
de l'humilité dans ce métier là à un
moment donné elle a pas eu d'humilité on
va pas pour elle
elle est sur un grand parti de ça
deux parties dominants en France pendant
des années et le Parti socialiste mais
enfin Hidalgo va pas être remboursé
également
vous allez avoir des travaux dans Paris
là je peux te dire qu'on se rembourser
allez les gars
allô Patrick dis-moi source d'un tunnel
mais je trouve que c'était sympa
non mais c'est un truc de fou non mais
il y a pas eu un commentateur jusqu'à
aujourd'hui qui avait vu un tel score
enfin le score et d'une violence
incroyable il n'a jamais ce score n'a
jamais existé ni pour la gauche il y
avait un monde qui avait fini pour la
droite incroyable d'être en dessous de 5
% ah non mais il y aura un avant et un
après Valérie Pécresse mais c'est
Valérie
de se reconstruire il y a plus de PS et
puis c'est sûr
à mon avis je pense qu'on va voir une
annonce prochainement dans la forêt vont
mérite Paris hôtel de ville
18 pièces
rénover non mais c'est vrai que les
Parisiens n'ont pas voté pour elle mais
non
mais ni les Parisiens
quand même attention c'était engagée
lors de la deuxième édition de la Mairie
de Paris à ne ouais en plus à ne pas
être se présenter c'est
2% ah ouais là ils sont
on est à 2 % là on est en train
d'exploser